the big thing is minimize your exposure
to the heat so do things earlier in the
morning or later in the evening hours
and just because your kids are playing
in the water that doesn't mean they're
being exposed to dehydration and heat
exhaustion dehydration basically starts
off you may feel a little dizzy you may
feel a little weak you may have dry lips
know the difference between heat
exhaustion and heat stroke heat
exhaustion symptoms include dizziness
being very thirsty heavy sweating nausea
and weakness heat stroke symptoms can
include confusion dizziness and falling
unconscious also keep an eye out for
heat rash if he does kill it's very
deadly and so it's a constant yearly
reminder that's why summer camps are
taking extra precautions especially this
week says centennial hills ymca camp
coordinator christopher olmsted we are
an outdoor summer camp so we have to
utilize the outdoor pool we utilize the
park so it's just making sure that we're
utilizing our outdoor spaces in the
safest way for our campers that includes
adding water stations and taking rest
breaks every 15 minutes along with
applying sunscreen before and after pool
time if we realize that it's a really
hot day and it's wearing down on them
we'll come inside armstead's advice
understand the potential consequences of
being in the heat for a long period of
time live local now